12 es gibt mehrere teile
bildungsferne schüler sollte es gar
nicht geben aber bei chantal bei danger
burak bei zähne bei den vier
hauptfiguren der reihe fackelte kann man
das kann man das sagen sie stehen mit
den inhalten eines konventionellen
liaplan soft linksfuß und zu ihrer
bildungsferne trägt auch bei dass sie es
mit einem lehrer zu tun haben der de
facto gar keiner ist
bei der eigentlichen platzierung und ist
jetzt ein platzwart auf euch oder warst
du hast den theken müller wie wir aus
dem ersten teil wissen ist eigentlich
ein taugenichts ein mann der ein
komisches ding drehen wollte und der an
dieser schule eigenen hängen geblieben
ist allerdings ist das so etwas wie ein
pädagogisches naturtalent dass man nur
erst einmal als solche erkennen muss das
ist eines der themen in dem nun
abschließenden dritten teil der föten
reihe final fakt das beste kommt erst
noch
ein leistungstest die gesamtheit
[Musik]
versprochen müssten die bewegung des
dritten teils und damit auch der drei
teile insgesamt ist letztendlich doch
sehr deutlich eine der integration so
sehr diese vier jugendlichen zuerst
einmal vielleicht grund geben würden
gerade in einer bildungs verrückten
nation wie deutschland wo die tiere
leben davon ist das alles auf bildung
ankommt dass diese leute zur besorgnis
geben müssten aber es lässt sich
schließlich in diesem dritten teil alles
eigentlich ganz gut einrenken alle
finden zu ihrer berufung die ich zur
schule gehen
das bei mir umsonst ist ja wenn sie zu
hause bleibt und es war irgendwie viel
dass ich manchmal so an als ob jemand
die tür für die zukunft zu helfen und
was das ganze vielleicht zusammenhält
sind die schauspieler die vielen fans ja
zweifellos ans herz gewachsen sind elias
m'barek hauptdarsteller sind sehr
charismatischer sehr attraktiver
darsteller sie aber durchaus auch zur
selbstironie lage ist hält das ganze
recht locker zusammen und auch die
jungen helden aus dem keller heraus ragt
die mit chantal die zentrale
identifikationsfigur spielt das sind
nicht eigentlich schauspieler im engeren
sinne sind jedoch sehr stark geben weil
es typen gefragt die denen es nicht auch
psychologische raffinesse oder etwas
ankommt sondern einfach darum dass sie
nachvollziehbar machen wie denn der
hektische alltag von jungen menschen die
unter stress darunter eben auch bildungs
straßen mehr als stress und so weiter
stehen wie das dann aussieht
vielleicht hat sie mobbing seminar das
die rakete und so ein hashtag war ich
habe schon vor zwei monaten gesagt dass
ich gemacht werden direkt die schüler
haben sich
[Musik]
ob es nun im strengen sinne gute filme
sind ist eine frage die gar nicht so
leicht beantworten ist sie sind auf
jeden fall sehr heutige filme und wenn
man an diesem dritten teil vielleicht
etwas aussetzen möchte was im grunde
auch musik ist denn er wird sicher sehr
erfolgreich sein dann vielleicht dass
das bora dagtekin möglicherweise auch
deswegen weil es der letzte sein wird
ein paar ideen zu viel hineingepackt hat
der film wirkt doch ein bisschen konfus
es fällt ein bisschen an einem inneren
bogen vor allem auch an einem
emotionalen bogen aber das könnte man
eben auch wieder sagen dass das eben ein
film ist für eine generation die ganz
andere auffassungen von emotionalität
hat willkommen in deutschland wir sind
hier um euer deutsch zu verbessern wir
beginnen mit euren namen erich heister
werden und seit zwei monate bin ich hier
ich bin seit drei monate in deutschland
unterschätzte danger bin seit 17 jahren
in deutschland